Kilis are zubin are in southern Turkey
40 miles from the Syrian city of Aleppo
the temporary camp accommodates refugees
mostly from Syria a shining example for
the visiting European Parliament
President Martin Schulz plasma shield me
the weirdest does he manage Marmee shame
behnazir be in one's own land in
deutschland on occasion then and this
could hear whether were fletchling's
problema and a try see 50,000 finishing
in an ammeter a Nazi million on one of a
daughter and calm when we are ya
understand 400,000 91 on who knows 16
thousand freshly when he done the AVD i
bethought vietnam was it a nude scene
turkey is believed to be sheltering more
than 1 million seven hundred thousand
Syrians who fled the war in their
country the day before in Ankara mr.
shorts met Turkish leaders anxious to
relaunch negotiations on their countries
accession to the European Union Turkey's
refusal to recognize the genocide of
Armenians 100 years ago was also raised
as was the Cyprus question